Elisabeth borne vous la voyez comme un
comme un signal d'ouverture c'est un
signal de co-construction il achète la
personne que l'assemblée n'est pas la
même qu'il y avait auparavant avec une
majorité absolue on est dans une réforme
absolument centrale fondamentale c'est
cette réforme de retraite tant de fois
repousser il y en a eu quelques-unes qui
ont été faites dans le temps mais on
voit bien parce qu'il y a un principe
qu'il faut rappeler aux Français à
l'heure où je vous parle il y a 34
milliards d'euros de déficit voilà et
donc il faut bien trouver des solutions
pour les petites retraites pour les
carrières longs pour les carrières
hachées et puis peut-être travailler un
peu plus et vous avez raison de dire que
65 ans c'est un totem mais je voudrais
préciser une chose c'est pas 65 ans
demain ou 64 ans demain ou semaine 63
ans demain alors côté vous êtes
favorable à 64 ans je vous réponds très
précisément la réforme est prévue à 2030
je dis bien 2030 c'est dans 7 ans ça
sera soit 63 soit 64 65 à l'heure
actuelle l'âge moyenne départ c'est
combien c'est 62,6 faut le rappeler à
tout le monde donc en fait l'effort
qu'on doit demander n'est pas un effort
insurmontable mais ça ne peut pas être
le même du monde il y a des métiers pour
lesquels je pense le métier de la santé
moi qui suis biologiste je sais que
l'infirmière les aides-soignants des
métiers très durs il y a d'autres
corporations pour lesquelles on leur
demandera pas cela donc il faudra
travailler un peu plus oui mais pas
maintenant il y aura justement ce
décalage dans le temps qui permettra
justement de faire en sorte de servir
d'amortisseur mais de raconter qu'on ne
bouge rien vous savez que tout change
pour qu'il y a du change comme le fameux
grand film que chacun connaît avec de
l'eau et le guépard c'est pas le sujet
si on ne change rien le trou s'agrandit
et c'est trousse s'agrandit on reste
avec des petites retraites alors Vigier
daik la rappeler les Français sont
majoritairement contre cette réforme
l'ensemble des syndicats contre cette
réforme également vous ne l'entendez pas
on entend tout cela
j'entends la crainte de celui qui à
l'heure actuelle c'est que par exemple
il doit partir à 60 ans libre en 10 64
ans ou 65 ans mais pour lui c'est un
changement complet si je me suis permis
d'insister sur le fait que d'abord
l'application de la réforme c'est pas
maintenant si dans plusieurs années donc
ça veut dire que c'est une nature me
semble-t-il rassurer Julien Aubert que
tu connais bien les républicains ont
voté vous le savez à plusieurs reprises
des amendements pour partir à 64 ans je
vais simplement le premier message qu'il
faut adresser aux Français c'est de dire
qu'on va travailler un petit peu plus
longtemps chacun fasse un petit effort
la deuxième chose sacrifice c'est le
sens en fait du message quand one ils
avaient demandé en disant on s'est
focalisé sur 65 ans on a peut-être eu
tort nous exécuter je pense peut-être
Emmanuel Macron elle va pas le dire
comme ça mais peut-être qu'on a eu tort
de trop parler de 65 ans et on rassure
les Français en disant oui vous allez
faire un petit effort mais un an ça
serait un an plus ça serait un truc qui
veut dire simplement
les Français doivent faire un effort la
deuxième chose j'en ai ras-le-bol et
j'ai ouvert le sait très bien cette
petite retraite à 85900 euros on a
proposé un point d'atterrissage à 200
euros la France insoumise dit rien
d'autre les socialistes rien d'autre et
là et c'est normal c'est de la descente
troisième chose à l'heure actuelle qui
sait qu'en France quelqu'un qui a une
carrière hachée vous savez à quel âge il
a une retraite à taux plein car il
arraché suite par exemple un accident de
la vie chômage ou une maladie vous savez
quel âge vous partez à la retraite un
taux plein à 67 ans alors nous nous
proposons nous nous proposons de faire
en sorte qu'on revienne par exemple
parce que 65 donc une avancée sociale et
après il y a un monsieur quand vous
dites-vous c'est pas Elizabeth borne ce
matin
sur notre antenne il a bien dit qu'on ne
toucherait pas à cet âge de 67 ans où on
peut partir à taux plein même si on n'a
pas fait le nombre de trimestres
mais moi je vais vous dire nous sommes
attachés dans la famille politique à son
équipe quand même à faire en sorte que
ceux qui ont eu des carrière les plus
difficiles les puretés ont aussi en
capacité j'imagine que gouvernement
voudra qu'on construit en tout cas nous
porterons aussi ce message et puis il y
a le sujet du financement sur lequel un
moment ou un autre je crois bien se
pencher quand tout socialise je le
reproche pas d'avoir fait la réforme
Touraine il nous expliquait vous en
souvenez le début du quinquennat de
Monsieur Hollande la retraite à 100 ans
c'était croix de bois croix de fer
quelques années plus tard on sait que
c'est 62,6 je me suis Guedj par exemple
souviens très bien il était un orateur
permanent du Parti socialiste il est
revenu à assemblée donc chacun sait
maintenant durant madame autant des
autres choses sur France Info hier matin
en disant quoi qu'il arrive ça va être
peut-être qu'on trouve un système de
financement complémentaire donc il nous
appartient et moi je crois que la
conjonction que nous vivons à l'heure
actuelle du Sénat qui a fait des
propositions de l'Assemblée avec sa
composition nouvelle fait qu'on est
obligé de co-construire c'est un acte de
responsabilité qu'on apporter vous avez
des français quand le quand le corps le
Conseil d'orientation des retraites nous
dit la trajectoire maîtrisée à horizon
2070 avec le système actuel quelque part
le corps nous dit il n'y a pas vraiment
urgence
et bien pardonnez-moi il y a urgence
parce que le rapport du corps je l'ai lu
comme vous l'avez lu d'abord il ne
reprenne pas une redit pas que le
déficit actuel c'est 34 milliards
deuxièmement il vous dit pas une
deuxième chose c'est que le retraites
sont financées
340 milliards de roue chaque année il
est finie ils sont financé comment par
les cotisations sociales mais simplement
autour de 80% les 20% mon compte ils
sont financés par budget de l'État ou
par des impôts et comme la tribia du
Julien Aubert en plus nous sommes un
pays dans lequel on vieillit plus donc
on veut y plus il y aura donc plus de
retraités on vit plus longtemps la
retraite en bonne santé et donc le
rapport du corps non plus ne traite pas
des petites retraites des carrières
hachées il ne dit pas combien ça coûte
pour une carrière achetée justement de
faire ce que nous proposons tout à
l'heure de ramener à 65 ans c'est 2
milliards d'euros il ne dit pas que
mettre une retraite minimum à 1200 euros
par mois pour une cotisation pour une
cotisation tout au long de la vie ça
coûte 3 milliards d'euros donc tout cela
c'est pas dit et enfin regardez les
perspectives de croissance et les
différents chiffres qui prend vous savez
du coup ce qui se passera dans deux ans
dans trois ans dans le pays quand on
connaît toutes les crises auxquelles
nous sommes exposés confrontés est-ce
que vous êtes certain qu'il y aura 5 %
de chômeurs en 2040 ou même avant nul ne
le sait donc franchement est-ce que oui
ou non si on bouge pas les retraites
elles baisseront est-ce que oui ou non
on le veut non et quand ils ont été
injuste est-ce qu'on le veut ou non non
et enfin la pénibilité on n'a pas encore
parlé ici moi je propose nous nous
proposons une démocrates que les
partenaires sociaux sont partent ce
sujet il faut aller beaucoup plus loin
sur la prévention il faut peut-être
aller sur des années de réfraction par
rapport au tout plein je m'explique il y
a des métiers très difficiles j'ai pas
au député c'est pas aussi nature des
décider quels sont les référentiels et
les métiers dans lesquels et bien on
leur demande pas justement de travailler
jusqu'à 63 64 ou 65 ans en disant mais
vous partirez avec une retraite à taux
plein de c'est pas encore tranché non
c'est pas tranchée il va y avoir une
discussion vous avez vu que la première
ministre reçoit les partenaires sociaux
c'est des sujets où les partenaires
sociaux pourraient pas d'accord entre
syndicats et patronat sur les critères
de pénibilité
Emmanuel Macron on a enlevé certains qui
avaient vidé en place par ici mais tout
ça c'est pas encore tranché et puis on
aura le temps de l'aider
pas que ça serait bien pardonnez-moi
est-ce qu'on paye pas que ça serait bien
qu'il est parti dans ce dont c'est la
mission en leur donne quelques mois pour
se mettre d'accord sur des métiers sur
lesquels on met des vraies actions des
prévention plus fortes que celle qu'on
connaît et quels sont les dispositifs
parce que c'est eux qui doivent repérer
branche par branche pardonnez-moi les
métiers ne sont pas les mêmes en
fonction des qualifications c'est plutôt
le boulot des partenaires sociaux que
des parlementaires qui est vous allez
caresser les députés les républicains
dans le sens du poil dans les jours dans
les semaines qui viennent pour qui vous
rejoignent sur ce texte je l'appelle
alors responsabilité est-ce qu'ils ont
toujours dit Valérie Pécresse pas les 65
ans le Sénat régulièrement c'était à
pied à l'instant 64 ans une fois plus je
répète faut pas faire les fautes de
communication c'est pas 64 ans demain
matin arrêtons de mentir aux Français
il faut être honnête en 2030 mais la
vision qui nous regarde la deuxième
chose
d'ailleurs Julien Robert il a fait
référence et c'est très important
pourquoi la France c'est le dernier des
pays d'Europe pour le taux d'emploi des
seniors faut savoir ça 34% des seigneurs
de plus de 55 ans travaillent encore
pourquoi faut qu'on trouve des solutions
pour de faire en sorte qu'il y ait plus
de transmission de savoir peut-être avec
des situations progressives d'activité
peut-être avec des baisses de
cotisations patronales pour qu'on les
incite à plus rester dans l'entreprise
il faut aussi permettre à ceux qui
veulent travailler plus de faire des
cumules en retraite regardez la crise du
covid on n'a pas demandé à des médecins
retraités à des infirmières à des gens
de venir donner un coup de main il y a
des gens qui ont envie il y a des gens
qui préfèrent avoir une vie différente
non mais moi je suppose aussi pour une
forme de tension
mais j'entends les républicains ont
toujours été sociés de ligne donc c'est
bien qu'en responsabilités disent la
même chose ce que je veux dire faut pas
que c'est une réforme pour rien moi une
fois que je reviens les cariérarchie le
cumulateur retraite le retraite à taux
plein 65 ans ce sont pas des ce sont des
choses qui sont important ce pays doit
enfin traiter ces choses-là et quand
j'entends les insoumis de socialistes
comment ils vont faire les spécialistes
ils expliquent qu'on va revenir à la
retraite à ce que s'entend vous savez ça
me rappelle les vieilles les vieilles
musiques qu'on a entendu si longtemps
avec François Mitterrand François
Hollande non ça n'est plus possible
pardonnez-moi donc sinon ou alors on
sent que tu arrives des petites
retraites et ça ça n'est pas possible
nous allons être nous la première
majorité qui fera passer à plus de 1000
euros et c'est la bonne des choses qui
conditions énergétiques du coup que l'on
connaît actuellement soyez déplacements
c'est indigne de laisser des gens avec
850 ou 900 euros par mois on va penser
ces petites retraites à 1200 euros Jules
Philippe
salut le message qu'elle a fait passer
ce matin en parlant plus d'acheter totem
à 65 ans c'est-à-dire qu'elle est dans
une
c'est difficile
je vous réponds très précisément d'abord
un c'est son état d'esprit de vouloir
trouver des solutions mais je salue ce
que vient de dire la première mise ce
matin ça montre façon dont elle a envie
d'aborder cette réforme structurer les
majeure et la pour l'assurance chômage
et ayant été très impliqué pour mon
groupe il se trouve que dans le décret
il a été plus loin que ce qui avait été
au départ annoncé donc elle est revenue
à la case départ dont taxe c'est ce
qu'il fallait faire très bien elle a
reconnu en quelque sorte que ce volet du
texte était trop dur pour les chômeurs
j'étais pas initialement ce qui avait
été discuté parce qu'on a eu une
commission avec les sénateur il y a eu
des discussion avec les partenaires
sociaux ces types un peu trop dur comme
quoi elle a su prendre le coup du pays
comprendre et décider si le boulot d'un
Premier ministre donc elle reculera sur
la forme de retraite comme elle recule
sur le sur la fin de séance
de retraite non mais c'est facile de
dire c'est un recul non si déjà on
arrive en 2030 à faire partir les gens
64 ans mais en règle tous c'est sur quoi
j'ai insisté tout à l'heure c'est pas
uniquement là j'ai travaillé un peu plus
longtemps c'est tout le reste on parle
jamais du reste moi une fois depuis les
Carias et les femmes qui ont des
carrières difficiles les chômeurs qui
ont des carrières difficiles et les
petites retraites on va en faire régler
cela or par des lois tous les partis
politiques sont liés là-dessus et je
vous dis au fin du fin on verra
l'Assemblée en tout cas moi je le dirai
aux insoumis et je le dirai
rassemblement nation oui ou non ce que
vous êtes d'accord pour qu'on mette les
petites retraites ensemble de 100 euros
s'ils disent non ils vont pas la réforme
s'ils disent oui ou si ça tiennent c'est
à dire qu'ils soutiennent cette démarche
on sera le rappeler